all right here's the first story ladies
and gentlemen this is
massive
from timcast.com donald trump announces
mar-a-lago was raided by the fbi the doj
is currently investigating january 6 and
alleged efforts to overturn the 2022
election
i know that timcast.com is officially
newsguard certified which is huge it's
good news right we'll talk about that
later but i also want to make sure we're
just clear the hill is reporting
definitively the fbi raids trump's
mar-a-lago so while many outlets are
saying trump announces it's happened
there are there's at least the hill
saying it's definitive i have another
journalist who messaged me confirming
through multiples they say confirming
through multiple sources the fbi has
raided donald trump's home
they say or i should say we say over
timecast.com president donald trump
announced the federal bureau of
investigation has raided his private
real estate in florida mar-a-lago is
quote currently under siege raided and
occupied by a large group of fbi agents
the former president said in a statement
around 7 pm i mean this is this is
happening right when we're all excited
larry's here we're getting ready for the
show
he goes the fbi is raiding trump's house
and i was like what yeah it's like okay
is it going to be crazy they say the
purpose of the search was not
immediately clear trump noted that
agents executing a search warrant even
broke into his safe the doj has
accelerated its investigation into the
january 6 attack on the capitol and
further examined trump's actions to
overturn the 2020 election results uh
2020 election results to reign in power
according to the hill
so
civil war what
i don't think so i think that this has
been planned for a hundred years i'm not
talking about the raid on trump i'm
talking about technocracy and the you
know the military and well not the
military part of it came in the 40s and
50s with the opportunity after world war
ii to establish global dominance but
like the federal reserve they really
want to control the environment this is
just another stepping stone as far as
i'm concerned i think it's a very scary
development
i i thought at first people who said if
donald trump gets indicted or if he gets
prosecuted for alleged insurrection uh
we we would be having some sort of
violence in the streets i don't i no
longer feel this hyperbole this is very
scary you know for the entirety of
trump's presidency hillary referred to
the election of 2016 as having been
stolen she called donald trump
illegitimate
to the point where 67 percent of
democrats according to a yougov poll
believed that the russians changed vote
tallies in 2016 to get donald trump
elected jay johnson the department of
homeland security secretary testified
under oath the russians tried but they
failed to change a single vote tally in
2016. yet a super majority of democrats
believe that they did 78 of democrats
believe the russian interference changed
the outcome of the election and j
johnson testified we don't know we'd
have to have a world where there was
interference and one where there wasn't
and compare the two so we can't do that
we just don't know but 78 of democrats
according to a gallup poll believe the
russian interference changed the outcome
of the election in other words a greater
percentage of democrats believe
2016 was stolen the republicans feel the
same thing about 2020. hillary joined a
lawsuit jill stein to overturn the
wisconsin election uh and uh and filed a
separate motion to have the recount done
by hand nobody calls her a purveyor of
the big lie her social media platforms
have not been shut down even though she
said as i said for four years donald
trump is an illegitimately elected
president it's a double standard that
slaps you in the face hillary skated
when she clearly violated the espionage
act she had a private server in her
basement she got and received secured
information classified information lied
about it and skated and the and the law
does not require any intent but james
comey did this big presentation at the
end of it he said but she lacked the
intent the statute does not require
intent she skated this is double
standard and it's outrageous and there
might very well be violence in the
streets now because there's a couple
ways i think we can we can look at it
depending on how you want to give the
benefit of the doubt to democrats donald
trump was very passively looking into
the ukraine dealings of the biden family
for doing such he was accused of trying
to dig up dirt on his political rival
just before the upcoming election even
though joe biden had not announced or
even hinted that he would be running for
president i mean this is like a year and
a half before he made his announcement
at all
they impeached donald trump for this
right we do have evidence of potential
malfeasance i should say joe biden did a
quid pro quo with the president of
ukraine fire the prosecutor or you're
not getting the billion dollar loan
guarantee and they said well
it was in line with foreign policy
that's not the point the vice president
doesn't have the authority to make these
threats right as it happens his son was
on the board of barisma barisma's
founder was being investigated by that
prosecutor who ended up getting fired
because of biden now you could argue the
democrats
are looking at that and genuinely
believing that's what trump was doing
and this is what we've seen from them
they've repeatedly said you have to play
the game the republicans are playing if
they really believe that's what trump
did then this is a tit-for-tat or we can
operate on the assumption they're
hypocrites and liars they accused trump
falsely and then are now doing exactly
what they claimed he was doing and of
course uh hunter biden and joe biden are
getting a complete pass so far
joe biden has said repeatedly he knew
nothing at all about his son's business
dealings they got the laptop the laptop
was dismissed as russian disinformation
by 51 so-called intelligence operatives
right before the election sixteen
percent of biden voters believe that had
they known about this story they would
not have voted for biden uh and and six
percent right sixteen percent sixteen
percent of sixteen percent of biden
voters say had they known about the
hunter binding laptop story which was
suppressed by twitter suppressed by
facebook they would not have voted for
joe biden clearly the election then
would have been uh in favor of donald
trump uh and donald trump is referred to
as the big guy getting ten percent on
the laptop uh and they've and uh joe
biden a hundred by the complaining that
his dad gets back
you mean uh hunter biden referred to his
father as the big guy and the big guy
gets ten percent and they've done this
again and if you watch cnn you watch
msnb what i call msnb he ha it's like
this story doesn't even exist but but on
sunday even brian stelter of cnn their
uh their media guy even he said this is
not just a right-wing story it is
something that's very serious and could
jeopardize biden's presidency i want to
read this statement from donald trump
here for you guys um his announcement
that this rate happened he said
these are dark times for our nation as
my beautiful home mar-a-lago in palm
beach florida is currently under siege
raided and occupied by a large group of
fbi agents
nothing like this has ever happened to a
president of the united states before
after working and cooperating with the
relevant government agencies this
unannounced raid on my home was not
necessary or appropriate
it is prosecutorial misconduct the
weaponization of the justice system and
an attack by radical left democrats who
desperately don't want me to run for
president in 2024 especially based on
recent polls and who will likewise do
anything to stop republicans and
conservatives in the upcoming midterm
elections such an assault could only
take place in a in broken third world
countries sadly america has now become
one of those countries corrupt at a
level not seen before they even broke
into my safe
what is the difference between this and
watergate where operatives broke into
the democratic democrat national
committee here in reverse democrats
broke into the home of the 45th
president of the united states i mean
it's absolutely insane um
i think he missed an opportunity i'm not
the biggest fan of trump but i do think
he's the funniest president that what if
while they were raiding his place that's
when he just stood outside and announced
he was running for president defiantly
as they're like just moving safes out
he's like by the way i am running for
president i think that's the move i
agree i actually said this a couple
weeks ago donald trump needs to announce
now before they try and pull some bs
like this
i also just want to say i don't think
they care
i don't think they care when he
announces whether he announces they
intended to do this it's just again
absolutely completely outrageous
steve bannon was just prosecuted for for
refusing a subpoena by the january 6
committee found found found guilty um
eric holder refused a subpoena by the
republican for information on fast and
furious they referred it to the court
and the federal judge was appointed by
by obama throughout the uh throughout
the uh the lawsuit again just double
standard
yeah uh bannon was was charged with a
misdemeanor that was a misdemeanor what
he got found it was i think it was two
misdemeanors because of what like two
requests or something yeah i just wanted
to also say
no violence in this street you guys like
if we you know if we because we talk
about um
yeah that would be the worst possible
thing because it's gonna hurt of course
it would be yes a hundred percent and
it's also well because it's bad yes it's
wrong no but also like we talk about the
both side stuff right we talk about the
bow side stuff with this where it's well
we wouldn't have wanted obama to be
raided right so we don't want trump to
be raided it's the same thing with
violence in the street for everyone who
rightfully condemned violence in the
street when it was the left it's like we
don't want to do that however
i think people on the left as well when
something unconstitutional happens when
something shady happens when people need
to be held accountable still make your
voices heard the media should still
cover this responsibly but yet we don't
need to uh no pitchforks well people on
the left uh because donald trump got
elected in november of 2016. there was
violence in four
over four days in 40 different cities a
number of people were arrested and when
donald trump was inaugurated in january
of 2017 200 people were arrested in
washington dc protesting the the
inaugural so the idea that
donald trump supporters are more violent
than hillary supporters is just bs no
well and that's what's so frustrating is
i wish that
i wish that people and i say this every
time i'm on the show would have
principals and not parties and that
means if your side is doing the thing
that you criticize the other side for
not only should you call it out you
should be more upset
but that describes the right not every
single person on the right obviously but
today the right as the media describes
it is an amalgam of a bunch of different
political parties i mean libertarians
like it's funny when
they they meme dave smith because he
makes a tweet about the leftover
reacting and they say here's you
overreacting and it's like january 6.
it's like dave smith's a libertarian
right he rags on trump all the time
smith's also a comic hey what's up dave
right
so so the issue is like
whatever they describe the right as is
actually constantly pointing the finger
like hey that was bad you shouldn't do
that
whatever the left is is completely
oblivious or just outright does not care
and when you call them out they call it
what about ism i hear that all the time
it's called what about us
benny thompson is the chair of the
january 6 committee january 2005 after
george w bush gets re-elected he joins
88 other democrats uh to overturn the
election uh claiming that there was a
voter manipulation in the debal voting
machine in ohio
and wasn't successful but he did not
want those electors to be seated nobody
called him threatening the integrity of
our democracy uh and democrats tried to
uh challenge electors in 2000 al gore to
this day believes the supreme court put
george w bush in the supreme in the uh
in the white house uh maxine waters and
others challenged 2004 along with benny
thompson and more more states were
challenged by the democrats in 2016 in
january than donald trump challenged in
2020 in january but but here's here's
the issue
you've got a cult and everybody else and
i feel like
we can say that stuff all the time we
can make the memes and post the videos
maybe maybe it will
you know
wake a lot of people up but there is
still a massive base of people that
don't know don't care and even if you
tell them that they're going to say so
what i know they're driven by tribalism
and that's the problem right i think a
lot of people
on the left and in the on the right they
don't even realize
the scope of the bubble they're in they
don't know about the algorithms they
don't know about fact checking they
don't know they just see what the
algorithm gives them and it's usually
people this is what happened to me it's
usually just people who agree with them
and then i hear someone like larry
talking about even things about student
debt and black lives matter before the
show that literally i didn't know
now it's not
necessarily the average person's fault
you know this is our job right but it's
not the average person's fault for not
knowing it is their fault
for once you do find out something that
changes your narrative not going oh damn
okay maybe i need to change my mind or
look at that in a more open-minded way
can i just want to point out how
deluded deranged i think the democrats
are jamie raskin
sent me a text asking for money for a
political campaign
jamie raskin the guy who falsely who
smeared me on january 6 hearings
including a clip of me reading a fox
news article alongside other people
calling for a red wedding she texted me
saying
i need your help please donate now he
was he was by the way one of the 88
democrats that voted not to certify the
election in ohio in 2005 january like
unsubscribe
we're we're busted look i say i've been
saying civil war for some time not be
here's what people miss there's
single-layer issues and that seems to be
the only thing the left understands they
don't understand what comes next but
there are even many people that that
don't see beyond uh you know the first
second or third layer of events back in
2018 when i'm watching
people fighting in the streets my point
when i said we're on track for a civil
war is that the culture war you're
seeing on the ground is going to reach
the highest level of government there's
no indication it won't be the case now
we're at the point where the fbi has
just raided the home of a former
president
you can't get any higher than that the
doj of a democrat administration has
raided the former republican
administration president's
house
they've arrested several of his
administration officials they've
shackled them it does not get any higher
than this
this shows the country to the highest
degree has bifurcated the good what
comes next
i don't know kansas believe in kansas
with what's going on the abortion voting
the uh the only reason i'm very hopeful
that there's not going to be a civil war
is because people on the right have guns
and most people on the left don't know
how to fight that's not the issue though
the issue is the doj has been weaponized
well that's not good so you hear people
on the right say oh the right's got guns
what is the left has well the socialists
have guns the socialist rifle club rifle
association exists and democrats are
weaponizing law enforcement in ways that
conservatives won't do thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you